in you that will have you wondering if
kids really do need more internet
supervision a 13 year old is headed to
court after having three incidents of
swatting attributed to him swatting is
that thing where somebody calls in a
false incident to the police in order to
bring in swat teams to the location
under the misapprehension of a serious
situation in a less adorable version of
kids doing the darndest things the
teenager is set to appear in juvenile
court in April duty with hertz's it's
expected that when this happens he'll
probably be put on probation the boy
whose name hasn't been released said he
admitted to being responsible and that
he felt he was wrong one of his targets
with quote a rival minecraft player
although the expected punishment appears
to be light in this case that's largely
due to the boys age last month a 19 year
old was arrested on suspicion of
swatting and faces up to five years in
jail if he's found guilty like with all
our stories on this sort of thing the
moral here is don't SWAT people if to
pursue she will keep you updated on all
the latest so stay tuned to gamespot